what's the importance of the role of mr
elon musk in this
so
um
you know it's all fun and games but
here's a human who tweets about the
importance of freedom of speech and buys
twitter
what are your thoughts on the influence
the positive and the negative possible
consequences of this particular action
so you know if he is going to succeed in
if he's going to be one of the major
reasons why we decarbonize quickly and
why we get to mars then i'm willing to
cut him a lot of slack
so i have an overall positive view of
him now where i'm concerned and where
i'm critical
is
we're in the middle of a raging culture
war and this culture war is making our
institutions stupid it's making them
fail um this culture where i think could
destroy our country and by destroy i
mean we could descend into constant
constitutional crises a lot more
violence you know not that we're going
to disappear not that we're going to
kill each other but i think there will
be a lot more violence so
we're in the middle of this raging
culture war it's possibly turning to
violence
you need to
not add fuel to the fire and the fact
that he declared that he's going to be a
republican and the democrats are the bad
party
and you know as an individual citizen
he's entitled to his opinion of course
but as an influential citizen he should
at least be thoughtful
and
more importantly
companies need companies need and i
think would benefit
from a geneva convention for the culture
war in which
because they're all being they're all
being damaged by the culture we're
coming to the companies what we need to
get to i hope is a place where
companies
do they have they have strong ethical
obligations about the effects that they
cause about how they treat their
employees about their supply chain they
have strong ethical obligations
but they should not be weighing in on
cultural war issues well if i can read
the exact tweet because part of the
tweet i like
he said in the past i voted democrat
because they were mostly the kind the
kindness party
but they have become the party of
division and hate so i can no longer
support them and will vote republican
and then he finishes with now watch
their dirty tricks campaign against me
unfold
okay
what do you make of that like what do
you think he was thinking that he came
out so blatantly as a partisan
because he's probably communicating with
the board
with the people inside twitter and he's
clearly seeing the lean and he's
responding to that lien he's he's also
opening the door to the
to the
potential bringing back um
the former president
onto the platform and also bringing back
which is probably looking at the numbers
of the people who are behind truth
social
saying that okay it seems that there's a
strong lien in twitter
uh in terms of
the left
um and in fact from what i see it seems
like
um
the current operation of twitter is
the the the
the extremes of the left get outraged by
something
and the extremes of the right point out
how the left is ridiculous like that
seems to be the mechanism
and and but and then it's
it's uh
that's the source of the drama and then
the left gets very mad at the right that
points out the ridiculousness and
there's this vicious kind of psychology
that's the polarization cycle that's
what that's what we're in there's
something that happened here that's
there's a shift where there's a decline
i would say in both parties towards
being shitty yeah okay looks what
everything with the parties that's not
the issue the issue is should the most
important ceo in america the ceo of some
of our biggest and most important
companies so yeah so let's imagine let's
imagine five years from now like two
different worlds in one world the
the ceo of every fortune 500 company has
said i'm a republican because i hate
those douchebags or i'm a democrat
because i hate those nazi racists
that's one world where everybody declare
everybody puts up a thing in their
window everybody it's cultural
everywhere all the time 24 hours a day
you pick a doctor based on whether he's
red or blue everything is culture war
that's one possible future which we're
headed towards the other is we say you
know what political conflict should be
confined to political spaces there is a
room for protest but you don't go
protesting at people's private homes you
don't go threatening their children you
don't go doxing them
we have to have channels that are not
culture war all the time when you go
shopping when you go to a restaurant you
shouldn't be yelled and screamed at when
you buy a product you should be able to
buy products from an excellent company
you shouldn't have to always think
what's the ceo what is that i mean what
an insane world but that's where we're
heading so
i think that elon did a really bad thing
in in in launching that tweet that was i
think really throwing fuel on a fire and
setting a norm in which
businesses are going to get even more
politicized than they are and you're
saying specifically the problem was that
he picked the side
as the head of yes as the ceo as the
head of several major companies
you know of course we can find out what
his views are you know it's not like
it's just i mean actually with him it
may be hard to know but you know it's
not that a ceo can't
be a partisan or have views but to
publicly declare it in that way in such
in a really insulting way
this is throwing fuel in the fire and
it's setting a precedent that
corporations are major players in the
cultural world and i'm trying to reverse
that we've got to pull back from that
let me play devil's advocate here so
because i've gotten a chance to interact
with quite a few ceos
um there is also a value for
authenticity so i'm guessing this was
written while sitting on the toilet
and
i could see in a day from now
saying lol just kidding there's a
there's a human there's a lightness
there's a chaos element and that's the
chaos is not
yeah that's not what we need right now
we don't need more well so yes there's a
balance here
the chaos isn't engineered chaos it's
really authentically who he is
and i would like to say that there's i
agree with that it's a trade-off because
if you become a politician so there's a
trade-off between
in this case maybe authenticity and
civility maybe like
being calculating
about the impact you have with your
words versus just being yourself and i'm
not sure
calculating is also a slippery slope
both are slippery slopes you have to be
careful so when we have conversations in
a vacuum and we just say like what
should a person do
those are very hard but our world is
actually structured into domains and
institutions
and if it's just like oh you know
talking here among our friends like we
should be authentic sure
but the ceo of a company has fiduciary
duties legal fiduciary duties to the
company he owes loyalty to the company
and if he is using the company
for his own um political gain or other
purposes or social standing that's a
violation of his fiduciary duty to the
company uh now there's debate among
scholars whether your fiduciary duties
to the shareholders i i don't think it's
the shareholders i think many legal
experts say um it's the company is a
legal person you have duties to the
company employees owe a duty to the
company um so he's got those duties and
i think he you know you can say he's
being authentic but he's also violating
those duties
so that's it's those it's not
necessarily filing a law by doing it but
he
certainly is shredding any notion of
professional ethics around leadership of
a company in the modern age
i think you have to take it in the full
context because
you see that the
he's not being a political player he's
just saying quit being douchey suppose
the ceo of ford says you know what
um let's pick a group well i i shouldn't
do a racial group because that would be
different let's just say uh you know
what
left-handed people are douchebags i hate
them like why would you say that like
left-handed people what you said now is
not not either funny or like-hearted
because i hate them it wasn't funny i'm
not picking you i'm saying that
statement words matter
there's a lightness to the statement in
the full context if you look at the at
the timeline of the man there's
ridiculous memes and there's non-stop
jokes that my big problem with the ceo
of ford is there's never any of that not
only is there any of that there's not a
celebration of the beauty of the
engineering of the different products
it's all political speak channeled
through multiple meanings of pr there's
a there's there's levels upon levels
upon levels where you think that
there it's it's really not authentic and
there
you're actually by being polite by being
civil you're actually playing politics
because all all of your
actual political decision making is done
in the back channels that's that's
obvious here here's a human being
being authentic and actually struggling
with some of the ideas and having fun
with it i i think this
represents the kind of positivity that
we should be striving for it's f it's
funny to say that because you're looking
at these statements
and they seem negative but in the full
context of social media i don't know if
they are so but look at what you said in
the full context you're taking his
tweets in context you know who doesn't
do that twitter like
that's the twitter that's the fun thing
the rule of twitter is there is no
context everything is taken in the
maximum possible way there is no context
oh yeah so this is not like you know yes
i wish we did take people in context i
wish we lived in that world but now that
we have twitter and facebook we don't
live in that world anymore so you're
saying
it is a bit of a responsibility for
people with a large platform to consider
the fact that there is the fundamental
mechanism of twitter where people don't
give you the benefit of the doubt well i
don't want to hang it on a large
platform because then that's what a lot
of people say like well you know she
shouldn't say that because she has a
large platform and she should say things
that agree with my politics i don't want
to hang it on large platform i want to
hang it on ceo of a company ceos of a
company have duties and responsibilities
and and you know scott galloway i think
is very clear about this he criticizes
elon a lot as being a really bad role
model for young men young men need role
models and he is a very appealing
attractive role model so i agree with
you but in terms of being a role model i
think
uh i don't want to put a responsibility
on people but yes he could be a much
much better role model there yeah i mean
to insult sitting centers by calling
them old i mean that's you know
yeah i won't do both sideism of like
well those senators can be [ __ ] too
yeah but yes that's fair enough respond
intelligently as i tweeted to
unintelligent treatment yes
yes um so the reason i like it he's now
a friend the reason i like elon is
because of the engineering because of
the work he does no i admire him
enormously for that but what i admire on
the twitter side is the authenticity
because i've been a little bit jaded and
worn out by people
who have
built up walls
people in the position of power the ceos
and the politicians who built up walls
and you don't see the real person that's
one of the reasons i love long-form
podcasting is it
especially if you talk more than 10
minutes it's hard to have a wall up yeah
it all kind of crumbles away so i i
don't know but yes yes you're right that
that
that
it's a step backwards to say
at least to me the biggest problem is to
pick sides to say i'm not going to vote
this way or that way that's um
be that
like leave that to the politicians
um you have you have much
like the importance of social media is
far bigger
than um
the bickering the short term big
covering in one political party it's a
platform
where we make progress where we
develop ideas through the
sort of rigorous discourse all those
kinds of things
you